the committee division it appeared on
Fox a legitimate a democratic the
renewal in do I contribute a fascinator
constitutional ban renew or paribus
rendezvous la vallée du sommet Avenue
committed a ratio completely Adonai
Estela to the Lahab conceivably Zeta de
Mistura said in F
[Music]
for the New York in philosophy Tara avec
la ville avec no vision issue to
rectifier
[Music]
[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen can I
please ask you to go back to your seats
so that we can start this closing
ceremony in due time we're already half
an hour late so we'll try not to delay
any further as president lumbers pointed
out we have guests waiting for us
afterwards for the reception we don't
want them to wait for too long a very
inspiring video to kick off this session
and it's a pleasure to welcome you to
this closing ceremony after what has
been a rather eventful year of
celebration of the 25th anniversary of
the committee of regions tonight of
course we will take stock of the past
and what has happened over the last 25
years but we will also look ahead at
what we can do to shape the future of
Europe and how the committee can
contribute as best as possible to this
future we will together reflect also on
how the committee can continue promoting
local and regional authorities and help
them play their do part in the work of
the European Union to this extent we
have a very impressive and long lineup
of speakers so that means not only now
I'm asking all the speakers to please
stick to their allocated time very very
carefully but I will certainly have to
remind you a couple of times throughout
the evening so please don't don't blame
me for it I think we all are going to
have to be disciplined and to start I
would like to enjoy
use the panelists on our stage tonight
miss Monica wolf Matisse who hardly
needs any introduction she's a former
European Commissioner in charge of
regional policy miss Ava Maiden well yes
sorry I couldn't sorry so miss ever
medal who is a member of the European
Parliament and also the president of the
European movement international vice
president matters of coverage from the
european commission also hardly needs an
introduction and mr. je sorry mr. je a
president of the European Economic and
Social Committee but before we turn to
our speakers I would like to first of
all give the floor to president
Lambert's
Mexico Nevada nerve shake a leg
Rosalie Bowman or a mimosa support Oppo
not as ecco Rancic on set a card a secre
siempre lo in Kouvola
arturo beaucoup de tomate de cette
Ostrovsky a particular Alamo at Arizona
permit emergency vehicle commodity
Aleksandar point we are personnel Giambi
Dawson region for a year at votre pe2
Riquelme grappa on Charlotte Watford a
nationality son Bujji
the lava large metal jvq of excellent
year the vimana force
havoc you need Ian Tate certainly prompt
are delayed the seborrhea proven well
area of a circle is 12 evasive avail
what window fatal event second committee
OPA division GC from a part of in this
baton a so don't reboot 11 February
said to circular committee or piada Rijo
Epoque t ma vie politic
to make combi cruces wallah promotion
Dolokhov risotto Antalya Lada phone's
dead wah socio raga connoisseurs dolo to
namida Malaysian Oh to Vienna Co mm en
Casa de vecinos dosage Ana's ET charlo
payin Donna photos of real anniversary
[ __ ] [ __ ] location Kosovo elaborate in
a tooth Sheila cooties 12 committee
revolver commode de la Li la particular
mode result in Sao Paulo Volkov our own
if a sedative motto 11 occasion is a
toast a collectivity territorial no
PadFone immortal no she deserves oh no
no Scott Dyer Yahoo Yahoo News Avvo are
obtained declaration de la conservative
lagu vanozza melting evo las
subsidiarity Wakulla proximity of a
listeria on fa una vaca cool compact
additional certain CD consoled asana the
region ii shop opera collectivity
territorial rested actuality sinews
Avenue reset process additional property
ofl massage the collectivity territorial
sunup asanas are Unitarian FA paula solo
combat continue clay groans association
rejoin the villa money or division in or
not bucola village on festival in
volusia pizza a very nice addition
apparent here job profit the earth to
severely president president the says
Association president Audrey it upon
wrong lapa whole okay Jesus Tom the man
Lucas I get a Makati jewelry
Unilever possibly a low wall calendar
committee Climaco social European on
calico soft not fair go home read a
proposal a canoe kelvil the committee
was a realist rather not
a cetacean euros a phone in a sushi on
SSF pakka locomotive OPA dele genre
vienna circle at appraiser the Saleem
episode event second atrocity co-op Sol
Maureen FET Elba metro neva noticed rod
nozzle helical it is no travel to
Donnelly peaceful lava near the Europe
affair facile Nouveau defeat in result
astronomy committee the feet on a fake
coma say if you conservators focus Apple
continued oppose a asada diba European
merci beaucoup profit attention Thank
You president Lambert's can I ask then
each of our guests tonight to give us
their short statement about the debate
and to help us kick off this ceremony in
the way it should
mr. je starting with you so thank you so
much for this opportunity thank you so
much president Lambert I will switch to
French he sidled I remem oh come on you
see Amy you know read it receives of the
year the said Sal dilemma sickly Pauline
are open to celebrate vote revenge a
maneuver Sarah Whittle Arizona Colantoni
Impreza G nuna celebration attorney era
not Rose wasn't a maneuver sell a Rondo
Vinicius a plenary pure disputed economy
predecessor a among feta the certain
long but I can FA mem evaluated
remastered
pora to see the deadlock ratio daaaaisy
org an efficient consultative European C
Pascal no Mambo not entrepreneurs and
the calories was the Seville is served
come on le territoire yeah
let Ravi concrete de travail ordinary Co
TVN avec le so treaty locale original
secrecy al por la vas a de sousa a
prosthetic on Bangalore kumanyika
bankers early news Ivanka Sutra specific
a porta de l'espace liquor open new
represent an oasis Iligan easy evil
representantes charity local territorial
own to leader obligación pala relativity
the petrified at all FS and apparel
Ascona Balaji a risky the solution FF DC
net reproach the situation to approach
the reality when ABC delivery to toe
it's a see if a conservative the
trans-pacific appurtenance possibly
choripán don't
mercy o president the war apply
knowledge we are an assist le premier de
Mirage the committee resin Marty city
policy the president a premier president
from the commit economy Kaiser OpenGL
almond suzanne team and among group
group drop it a prison lord la première
plenary committed arizona the president
blanco GYC few presidents a committee
said not our committee k resist a
technique man por la preparación the
plan air a parlor protocol acidity the
water committee's a test click on the
award a structure constant support dirty
fossil miss a 10 grand challenge a pass
Q&A team in initiative uniqueness pass
repeal the award is routine commune to
provide the service adieu assembly for
different gives on their all sueded ero
see Claudia ransom a premier
intervention you see Ramon it Tony there
is root a key was a big really 0-7 Cinco
diversity to
was the number in ombre blue la semana
repair open the villa de reso suppose an
example who notice member oaxaca meaty
juicy TOC said been initiative catalysis
allah president's the Caroline's Lambeth
kisses Italian villa villa reso Japan's
in tribal approach to complete a little
leniency Perla president la comisión
yep ratio deceit Illidan earring SETI
don't rate a protagonist Michael lines a
big family non-paper you're not tasty
and sampler keeper fallen on paper
subbu complicity is from Baku P Kappa
Delhi montón de ba too beaucoup de duque
more vcl confer the Quran in graffiti
Tirana buzina turn on paper so no
description officiel me Lana Turner on a
pre assembler in initiative declare chef
dated when mr president de sao paulo
dear yes oh yes a real met impede
ordered a set multiplication and finito
consultation today bad dialogue dunno
and some instructor permanent a new new
committee on Alex perience rely capacity
on aunt revived husband and contactable
arity the proposal system control the
tank or a vehicle summit and a low DC on
alacrity ensemble dial a commission of
coup de zone a multi-person
fazer a terrace on Quora to slaughter
and I saw you see graded our real
opportunity after grantee committed
Cooper a strip Emily would eternal
Vetrov linear issue to the copper a
sister Monica and Graham president come
II
Caroline Lambert you success at their
new era Dawn's Oh prophet Oh simple
Sally apology to Tamara conscience
recognizes the committee economy Kiera
pan pour la force do not recuperation
also reserved very much Thank You
president ie I think that before we come
back to all of our speakers and we
have several questions to ask them I'd
like to give the floor to mrs. Merced
espresso mrs. Brousseau you were the
first woman president of the committee
of regions and the third woman only so
far at least now you're still the third
but there's a fourth one president of
any EU institution so ladies first
and in your view what is over those 25
years the greatest achievement of the
committee thank you I will speak in
Italian grazie in tanto so no orgullosa
de esta la prima donna Presidente must
farad in on Estrin ultima the lunch on a
pail of very few Torah second oh so
start oh no the Presidente del da police
Bona de la vie Patera del del comité ato
de Larry Joanie second Oh Mako
Magistrato record at Oh Noi
siamo Russia Theodore Ventura UN so jet
Oh in contour Nabilah del debated to
Politico queer bracel abbiamo poor tato
multi-country booty abbiamo transfer ito
legislation European NOC territory in
Arizona sono molto spesso a Patera
legislative on Olerud aplicar knowledge
is Lazio a concrete cement any territory
nah bein wonky poor Totten NOC territory
least once'
la passione europaea quia be amok we see
Tycho pesto yo credo
Casilla UN rolos del comité Otto della
ragione que national tree solution
applause Walter a de la sua particle era
Tallis way importance a quest oh no es
nostro a ser un Genova front a a Alton
post a sole Evora bristle constitutio
nee na sua territory portal Satoshi Oni
message Italy
- Thank You mrs. Grecco
I'd like nap to ask you mr. Benson
you're the president of the Association
of European regions and definitely your
association has greatly contributed to
the creation of the committee of regions
so do you think that regions and cities
are now better represented in the
decision-making power of the Union thank
you very much and indeed ladies and
gentlemen as I feel I'm standing here at
this 25th anniversary of the of the
committee of region as a proud parent
and during these years
Europe has gone through its fair share
of challenges and successes and local
and regional authorities are
instrumental in delivering of policies
that can meet up with the people's need
and amplify and channeling our citizens
voice through the principle of
subsidiarity and the multiple gap
multi-level governance we need to
continue to work together the committee
of regions and the associations such as
a er so that the cities and the regions
and can continue involved be involved in
the decision making process and we need
to play a complementary role and help to
reinforce the regional and the local
dimension in the EU decision-making
process and I was just like to add that
it is especially important if we are to
solve the most pressing societal change
facing us today the climate change if we
are to live up to the commitments in the
Paris agreement and to reach the
sustainable development goals it will
require that the local and regional
authorities and the level are included
in the decision making process and
seeing that the majority of the goals
require sub-national and level of
involvement so yes but we can do more
thank you thank you thank you for being
a proud parent bit young for being a
proud parent of a 25 year old
mr. mr. blonde we saw you in the video
very very shortly in the presentation
you're the former president of the
committee of regions and you were the
first president of the committee to
stand here in front of the of the
plenary like we're doing tonight ma'am
not in this building though at the time
and you challenged at the time the
members it was in this building my
mistake
I thought the building for some reason
and I was here already at the time and I
thought the building was younger than
that the at the time you you challenged
committee of region members to be I
quote butter the less be horse European
which I sort of roughly translated by
you gave them a mission to represent the
European ideal so do you think that now
25 years later 136 plenaries later do
you think committee region members are
still rising to the challenge do parque
chico Jame Templeton de la Serna pal
secondo Momo pour etre de porto de
esperanza OPN am party creeper operation
petticoat occur TV repair hooray ho j KU
Judas say tempo Callisto combien Paco
Zarra Co Donahoe nuevo newell-fonda suka
news RFA appareil mobilize a co-anchor
Oprah fault
poker celebrity sparrows seconds of
insane General Henry pod Don Lee
premieres only this Richard Quebec
bokuden tezur0 president of excellence a
new permit ha the robot way they should
ray a sister showed up Wayne de Beauvoir
mercy
Lisa V Le Monde Hotel administration
share deals escapades uncovers Oh
renew bleep a circus own hottie ray
ooh sake eras on disparen me Osamu
Attica pobla de bois de Rivera risk
Ducati mo Michelle coleg forgiving
Sombra a parody remember voix de saber
de puta - common commensal de la canal
DiNozzo samara Deepika honto iveco t say
me no president del condor heigh ho up
our legislative agenda experienced the
presidency durango dhaka CEO rafael
Revere ensemble set a design company
irritate Gagne estelí not assembly
dong-chul new dimension politic Ella
permit a Madhava mercy illusory tsukino
survey a koi fish canary Peruvian a very
substantial appearance a testily a cream
shadow Kazama solicited fun to
complicate to package a the service
network make us a committee economic on
a day maje survey Basra positive Oh
danke
ana-lucia de faire la ferris hombre se
lo comet economic association so
differential pore affair may not we
don't eat a politic set a an R and a BA
Episode V mucosal a venir pollen say
says a pair of new Siham bien que renew
open vote ambos way David Ayer a ratio
curve L ratio us when the second you
open a poco when you open a novice way
Aaron Abruzzo in a park
Pascal nerve improve our participative
antara governance oppression Evo Shahani
vo to the concept of proximity impala
dear potato chips EG attractiveness pas
a novel la vie la responsibility rules
Ohio's only posthumous same attorney
intervention model a Menasha in effect
on
baku prevail upon say me
Shakira's ecco Dobbin donate Ananda
avocado caracas oficina de su coche
previa o sang yesica me today Rizzo no
son tus mobilize a donkey vato new
domain Sasaki compression porky
Durant Asia de participation are a
governess pork ASEAN fish support error
messages or later hang resume laser
recon Usama a exact same reprimanded no
Saddam be a reserve loco scenario Creed
II de confianza
Suho depopulation Porto Alvino open set
capacité de confianza cerca de the
conference pokerface paso de meses de
esperanza european a donkey in a Pontiac
dealer heavy Shaku are named Presque vu
Jerry shows the commutator of the
epidemic events and condiments and
causes copper mm skillet enter DDO jefe
Rinaldo Gemma's hombre twister apart a
second revision ma Zhong Ava Ava new
Rivera pre-determined array on the zone
edit a sincere canoe tous le dopo
carcass wanna sensibility Nazario
manaphy le message a pub lesbians
European law hope anibal's way
thank you very much mr. blonde for a
very passionate call and 25 years old
the passion is still there let me go
back to our speakers on the podium mr.
Markkula yes there you are
mr. Markkula you were also president of
the committee of regions what do you see
as the biggest the the most effective
challenge you had to face during your
term thank you thank you very much this
question is a challenging one but I
really think that the challenging issue
was how to get every one of you asked
350 members another 350 alternates to
work together to learn together and
really then put the putting the ambition
level higher than so far and with the
ambition level not in our speeches but
what impact what influence we can we can
receive and on that so thanks to the
good mentality with Curran so we in the
beginning we defined the draft for the
five-year priorities not only for two
and a half years and then another to
replace that and then we got the
feedback from the members and approved
by the plenary and we had those defined
and the priority actually number one was
growth we need growth in Europe but not
whatever it needs to be sustainable and
then we defined what does that mean in
concrete terms looking again to our
members it needs bottom up if I simplify
so how to get every city city driven
region to operate not only as an
authority but with their industry large
and small with their universities with
their schools every citizen and on
focusing on this and then we define
further on so we get their three kind of
major success factors that we put for
this five-year term entrepreneurial
mindset how to encourage that with
concrete measures throughout Europe
especially looking to the youth welcome
here as well to join this we had then
the second one was digitalization
use of digital ices and throughout the
activities and the third one was
actually cretins collaborating with the
partnerships based on smart
specialization what are the priorities
of each of the regions which we know now
are defined and then we need to
encourage you financing to focus more
more more and more on that so this means
really that we need to work more
together and then give the kind for the
next year's tomorrow's for our
collaboration on inter institutional
level but to the other commissioners as
well we need to achieve the United
Nations sustainable development targets
not only the climate all the 17s deities
have a clear impact on the on the
climate is you are now a challenge to
move ahead next week already proudly
this week in Madrid with cop 25 and then
ahead and of it for the next CR to
continue the work thank you thank you
mr. Markkula back to your neighbors
actually and I'm going to turn to you
miss middle first but I lost the same
question afterwards from mr. SEF Kovac
and you miss mrs. wolf Mateus how do you
think the the creation of the committee
of regions was perceived by your
institution in this case the Parliament
at the time back in 1992 94 and and how
is it perceived now thank you very much
good evening
honourable members near president
vice-presidents glad to be able to join
you tonight I'm also glad that the
committee of the region it's often
having their plenary sessions here in
the European Parliament plenary room
because I think it's a nice symbolic
many of my colleagues probably myself
included we often tend to say we're the
real representatives of the citizens
well I might surprise you that I
actually think and I have said it at
numerous occasions whether beat with my
own colleagues from Bulgaria that their
presence
here today whether in my discussions
with various members of n mayor's from
various regions such as the mayor of
Addis or the mayor of Warsaw or the
mayor of Helsinki just recently Marko
you know whether in our discussions I
actually really think the toughest job
is the job of local representatives
because indeed they're closest to the
everyday issues and problems of citizens
and the symbolic to which I meant made a
comparison earlier is that it's so nice
to have you here but have also members
of the European Parliament being present
in order for us not to compete who's
closer to citizens but to be able to
address the problems issue and causes in
the most meaningful and and fast way
possible when it comes to the to the row
of the region's they really do think
it's it's a crucial point of our
democratic process for and here I put my
head as president of the European
movement International I think for a
democratic and prosperous country it is
of great importance that we have the
energy of everyone and what I mean is
this is the central authorities local
authorities the business NGOs civil
society without any of these players on
all sort of levels of representations
who express the citizens energy the
lively dialogue in society will not be
possible but it also make European
legislation much more challenging and I
think much more heavier to deliver I
would end with two points because I
would have to leave a little bit earlier
unfortunately and one I think we have a
very big challenge as European
institutions and this is how to make
sure that Europe reaches each and every
citizen each and every region each and
every village city town capital we work
tirelessly but sometimes our work does
not translate to those regions where
they are still European
due to an economic reason they're forced
to leave their region I would to see
very Creed efforts taken in the next
couple of years to make sure that
Europeans are not forced to leave their
region
for economic reason to make sure that
they're given the opportunities to
prosper and develop in their region and
there it's a bit of a glove handed over
to the vice president of the Commission
I'm really glad that the Commission has
put forward I believe the most important
portfolio that a fourth side the
portfolio that would enable Europe just
to look beside its own problems but it
would enable Europe to look forward to
think about what we want to achieve with
Europeans in the next 5 10 15 years to
come you have to know that in my face
personally and in the face of the
European movement international you do
have a partner in that but I think most
importantly in the committee of the
region's and its members as well because
over the past years together with
President Lambert's and vice president
McCulloh we have done a number of events
to make sure that those visions ideas of
Europeans will be translated in a real
vision and a real foresight coming from
the European institutions in the next
couple of years I would like to end by
thanking and apologizing because tonight
is also an important evening for women
of Europe for the third time we are
gonna give as European movement awards
of the most distinguished women of
Europe South need to run basically to
the Royal Palace down the street to give
those awards in order to make sure that
talent in Europe irrespective of gender
or nationality or religion is nurtured
but also of women so that we make sure
that we don't have just one women
president of the committee of the
regions or four of institutions but
perhaps to to nurture and support those
women working tirelessly in every corner
of Europe thank you very much
thank you Miss middle so I would like
now to turn to you mr. Wolfe Matthias
what was the feeling of the Commission
when the committee of regions was
created what did the Commission think of
this new institution and what's the
feeling now as the sister Commission
Divya in Maastricht Treaty Wyndham
kesariya I'm Gazette stutter Vardi
building and representants they are
local and regional beats copper shaft of
our peer Sahib nur and Ganz Vista gabite
ah
Sameer Burgin ear Burgermeister the
United Press attend Regan alia actor /
tin Jetson and grow style Knutson Allah
went over Persia and China moon near a
farm site unless a puffin fauna Haim in
The Gazette ski bums shockable existed
felon I was a demon des voix de Ashtanga
Zack - Jesus for art in dialogue
Mettenberger Vernon burger and Ken
Diane's autumn of bezzerides política
after Natsu 9 order our Pearson Evenor
decommission had ceased si - Anne Frank
and their interns leave owned in contact
some re album moon and he had found Fort
Lee here comma 7 one who brings Alfred
fancy young shown the foul in ina and
president posizione valve he deploys its
own test area and raisin phallus me of
each diva Tiguan sue Guderian instructor
politic Matane MIT clear on disastrous
aesthetic yong-soo Discordian when Ella
and Reagan want for schlager Philip
actor Shalom jetsam dacquoise yawns
politic after name that Shirley had a
noise cameo Miss Anne Frank snitch light
see him hanged a who Institute CEO
Italian and escape of prefer strong they
are they are transistor or concurrence
first our PA Parliament and freaking
average danger assistance combines
humble
Denine flows to south shores deleon in
XANA bottoms from jiangsu startin once I
know Allah as Shahed egg mine
entre gone so fasting and he that
conscious Martin sang Politis escovitch
isten infer Gangnam yonder at lishka
vaccin with us - east is there a day of
disciples under Swedish Bellavia and
Gesellschaft model state does solidarity
cooperation on fan thoughtless hundred
for art mitten and offended to assignor
albeit farms are Stosh on partners often
tuition dingy beats copper shaft evil
endocrine scene in vague for hunger feed
much one distinct a dozen to your
appearance for Natron then the Yelich
that film via - Tito and Laguna de da de
Ali immittance leave and go wolf in hat
it's insufficient veiled white D gross
the reggae music financed item to my
farm south of le renard politic thank
you very much thank you
I spread in South Kovich the same
question to you what was the feeling 25
years ago in the Commission and and how
is the committee perceived now thank you
very much for these questions I think 25
25 years ago it was just five years
after the Velvet Revolution
fall of the Berlin Wall and I was a
desire of the new member states like
mine
Slovakia to join the European family as
soon as possible and I think that the
ambitious and very much forward-looking
people in the European Commission like
Jacques de or but also like Madame
Annika wolf mattiece felt already at
that time that to achieve big things we
have to be closer to the people we have
to reach better out to the region and to
talk to the people on the ground and
that was I think the
yeah why the committee of region became
so important and further developed to be
absolutely necessary for our success in
making sure that we have this
multi-level governance and that we
really can talk better and learn better
from the people who are running a local
authorities and if you look at it at the
perspective of today we still have the
same challenge they need to know better
how our policies are taking place on the
ground what could be the advice how can
we tailor made our policies to really
deliver the success and because I know
that our time is limited I would just
end up with three or four suggestions
what I think would make our cooperation
even stronger at first I really would
appreciate a lot to the work of
committee of regions but also of
Economic and Social Committee on active
subsidiarity now we have to put it into
the practice I see it as very much
upstream cooperation meaning that once
we are thinking about preparing a
legislation one we are thinking about
developing the policies so we should
have this early consultation so we can
get your contributions your input into
what then would become the the proposals
coming from the European Commission and
being debated very much in this building
of the European Parliament and among the
Member States in the council I think
that we should really focus on what I
see as a crucial question of this time
of course we talk about Green Deal
I mean there was the first college
session this morning we are going to
talk about how to make Europe more
digital how to deliver better and more
social Europe to our citizens but all
these questions come under one even
bigger umbrella question for me being
responsible
as madam member of the European
Parliament tomatoe said for foresight
what we need to do is a Europeans to
make sure that not only in 2030 but for
rest of the century will be on the same
same medal podium together with the
United States in China that it will not
be pushed aside that we will be one of
the biggest economy in the world biggest
trader the most socially irresponsible
and fair community on this planet
playing very responsible role towards
environment
towards the developing world and what we
need to do to be there how you are going
to take up the super competition for the
technological supremacy what we are
going to do in making sure that we would
be very strong in other parts of the
economy and I think this would be the
future oriented debates where I believe
we can really learn a lot from the
experience on the ground my second
suggestion would be I would like to ask
you to help me in my portfolio to reduce
administrative burden I know we are
talking very often how sometimes it's
difficult to apply European laws on the
ground how local authorities are
sometimes really having lots of
difficulties to make sure that they know
how to implement or use for example
European funds so my suggestions my
challenge to all of you would be please
let us know what is in the eyes of your
regions what are the three most
cumbersome legislative measures which
make your life difficult so we can make
a list and we can work on them who is
responsible for that is it really you
is it bad transposition or maybe it's
all of us and we have to do to make it
easier and to use it better and the last
point I would make is we need to discuss
how we are going to use the opportunity
for this grand Abbar European with our
citizens under the conference of future
for Europe we are starting our internal
discussions within the Commission very
soon we will involve you and I think
that without your participation without
your suggestions in what region which
questions what topics are relevant for
the people there this come
reigns would not have a success so there
are few concrete suggestions how we can
make also another 25 years as fruitful
as the first 25 and I am very much
together with all college of
Commissioner looking forward to this
close cooperation with you thank you
very much madam thank you vice
presidents of college and let us go back
to our speakers on the floor tonight and
I'd like to turn back to mr. vasco
Cordero mr. Cordero is a president of
the conference of peripheral maritime
regions mr. Cordero what do you think
are the actual complementarities between
the committee of regions on the one hand
and the major associations like yours
associations of regions and cities how
do you think they complement each other
and can work together president
Niraj is nurse members doc meet average
a loose term a 0 v - Evo fillet
matreoshka final tambaqui diversidad no
zone mess do complimentary Dodd Florence
exterior Frida Kahlo potentia moto de
trabajo de varias insufficient o sachika
da matta su papel kodama tie USA
objetive in fact Radames central no
subjective immune so people far
conscious objetives finish sage on fruit
du travail de todas estas en submitted
urgent share p.m. mood my short anoint
my vassal mentor consult IDO you example
concrete audience epilogue weasel em
with em poo concrete is subtitute
resembling present his at amento moment
angstroms ah Jackie a Silverados Vincent
one's Dogma today research is each day
not as part of the bourgeoisie no saw
the but the karatsu breaking crafts
there a quasar move to
yeah importante no Perkins Oh sentido de
calidad de NOSSA me son porky furtive a
mentos tambaqui nasa component equation
F 2 del Paxton causa yen camp women's do
travel mucho para committed urgency
Paris Juarez insufficient yay importance
averted prospective ours prosimians
consider multi TV pursue attend Sandoz
nervous president doc miss Amuro pea
oh no she Odessa Nara president the
commissioners lavender Lane proposes new
initiative regime one knee room upon
Francia so brief tour de ropa grand
objetive massage omitted a todos OS
organizations definite Ennis parts
Aparna so conferencia Dez Dez doin is
yell contrary decking cubes V dos
objetives niche plays near president
that me some participants miss induces
objetives s conferencia purty Paranal if
not Nissan de que que Ella pretend
Arkansas pork of toda raba non te ver
commission co-consul
oku parliamentary borough of toward a
rabbit ever considered on servers in or
icky
represent amidst former director who she
denounced toda raba my god
thank you thank you mr. coudair Oh miss
sportsy miss Percy you're the president
of the conference of European regions of
legislative assemblies calorie which is
a quite known also in this in this
organization and you have worked as such
with or on several initiatives like the
cohesion alliance or the initiative for
the integration of migrants what is the
added value of such projects for the
committee of regions and and how do you
bring them in Grassi in Tonto sanatorium
great cement over question vido Birla
possibility' di porta El Santo de la cal
rae a questa punta mentos cosas
importantes carto dice ahora seguramente
entre guardo in questa prema fossae day
fest Elementium beyond Mohsen tito
interventive karoke continuity respect
or quail augustama storia di questo
comet Otto
young Cady prospective H lation of windy
una bella vision and evil of every
futuro yonk a report Okura khal rhae
abou tonus wave on seonyu thomas will
implement a zeona kasey kahne credit
data probe in questa journée cuando el y
veinte lua de noviembre habla more ELISA
- aroma control senato las SEO Nestor
ordinary sous la subsidiary 'te nella
Pallavi amo present Otto bestowed Raja -
Mirotic aprender avi Oprah bunin
prosavana very significant real
importante de la celebración a track or
a calorie - telly al Kresta shot Sione
si de siiva prema del importance ax the
FARC / venir a la cama Sione led sono le
stands Delabar say echo ill nostro
intento estaba sempre [ __ ] di
cercariae a visionary in ostrich
histidine e
propio burke whele interpret a co-equal
a metaphoric a prima Safavid alguno
Rivoli breast Osamu esto John agree
Ferrante Cain quark a modo de servicio
de una parte
relaunch of Allah Placer County report
RNA territory quest a desicion EOS
distante questi significative etrog
wardi quindi questa Nostra collaborate
seonyeong Kayla Teva Allahu Alem lands
estado unum play no Pato kablamo in T so
Porter Avanti Contenta meant a sentiment
a cap endo / mental sense Oprah fondo di
questo nostro report di questo Nostrum
Pino
Dante so no Sade least once' atonte so
no study Liberty Vuitton TLS Alicia
tascioni sweet Emma Delhi Delhi me
grazie Oni Appalachian Avenue la demanda
You Valeo record RL importante lago roca
in Kalra safe a toenail Yannick on the
group P de la Bologna quali so no state
a portable sensibility tanta territory
Barba four-legged eyelids or a Cristo
proof equal a war okay initial mentor
and aviso in with a mentee queen low
delle grazie oniy a quail okay be
sentimental llamo sentido in the very
least it we're a demon or in
unaccompanied ah t I would own profit Oh
Shamu cocina pro Figueroa accion and
Ellen Ostra nazione Natalia doe Bella
nostrils from the schita Sione so no
study Rakolta Nell missing you Lily
Jaguar and vasectomy latisha set Quinn
Deacon suburban Acadia Wawro the far end
[ __ ] Tonto goatee no mo conquest in Plano
14 de la necesidad afar a really intense
so originally in sin so vertical ever
color a place in Austria penny on LST
Guccione ball Evaro
a I presume you in teaching Quay thank
you thank you for your wishes sir Albert
Bowyer also former vice president of the
committee of regions and you have
experienced several high points during
your tenure and one of them was the
discussions on the Convention on the
future of Europe another one was the
creation of what was at the time the
open days which in the meantime have
become the European week of regions and
sit
geez how do you think that particular
event reflects on the history of the
committee what do you think it says
about the institution thank you for
those comments and that questions and
let me begin by saying that the
committee reasons presence and indeed
impact at the Convention on the future
of Europe which we spoke all there was
an early successful start to fostering
cooperation between and within EU
institutions we sat for weeks and months
together at that convention I'd also
added strengthened the committee regions
links with cities regions and their
associations was a key raison d'être in
the open day event that was an
initiative which was suggested to me by
the administration in 2003 during my
presidency in the first year and many
may not know this in the first year
there were five or six city or regional
or Network offices engaged and probably
no more than a few hundred participants
the week the European week of regions
and cities this year has seen three
hundred and ninety sessions over 500
partners around nine thousand four
hundred participants from across the
Member States including by the way six
hundred politicians and indeed 67 MEP s
those are incredible numbers this
success in my view clearly suggests that
over the past 15 years this annual event
has bonded the committee regions with
the cities regions and associations of
the EU but we should now take the
opportunity to rebalance the European
week of cities and regions to give the
CEO our local region authorities and
indeed the European Commission an event
that will assist in the evaluation of
present
policies and programs and help set key
objectives for future years we are
celebrating the 25 year anniversary of
the Seaguar but 25 years actually means
that the COR is still a relatively young
institution learning from our history
the Cyr should seize every opportunity
to make the sea you are the key
delivering force for the interests of
local and regional authorities across
the EU and thereby the citizens of
Europe I mean thank you very much sir
Albert let's go back to our speakers up
on stage starting with you this time
vice-presidents F Kovac um what at what
time at what moment precisely would you
say that the work of the committee of
regions has made a difference in your
work when were you influenced by the
committee and more generally by regions
and cities of course there would be many
many examples but let me let me let me
pick two I would say one word a recent
one one was when we had a very important
discussion about the future of the
multi-annual financial framework and
where we had again that very difficult
discussion what should be the proportion
what should be the the financial budget
lines and even more importantly what
should be the future of cohesion policy
and I think that in this case the voice
of the committee of region is very
important one because the local regional
representatives know the best how the
cohesion policy is important and we know
that our work in having the Europe more
cohesive is not done yet we still have
big disparities among the regions and
the cohesion policy is the best recipe
and best instrument how to level up and
at the same time
how to generate the growth and at the
same time how to make the European
economy stronger bigger and more
competitive so therefore I'm very much
obliged then I think that the whole
European Commission very much
appreciated the support for the proposal
for mff and strong support for the
proposal for the next seven years budget
and second example would be strong
support of the committee of regions on
smart cities together with Mike
Bloomberg we realized that after the
important role the mayors and the
committee of region was playing in the
Paris agreement negotiations and that
excellent example which EU covenant of
mayors projected on the all atmosphere
around the Paris agreement negotiations
that it would be a sin not to use that
positive political power of the mayors
to help us to advance the issue of
modernization of the cities and and to
make it very visible for the people
because every mayor has to deal with
water with air pollution with traffic
jams with energy efficiency in in the
buildings with local industry with the
questions how to lower lower the carbon
footprint and co2 emissions and
therefore that example which EU mayor's
gave I can say proudly to the whole
world was then transformed into the work
of the Global Covenant of Mayors but of
course EU mayors are a very dominant
force so this been two examples which is
really show how valuable and important
our cooperation could be push for modern
good working cohesion policy and then
the close cooperation with the mayor's
vice presidents have courage and
definitely two very concrete examples
president je we have heard earlier on
about your very good relationship with
the committee of regions but in terms of
influence and examples in your work when
did you feel that the committee of
regions really had an influence on the
work of the Economic and Social
Committee or on your own work
thank you so much for this question I
would respond also following the example
of the vice president a man of safe
courage there are so many example in
this this work that we have done so
close and so so together a final in this
in this year but it will focus on two
men that are in the in the last years of
my presidency and and they think that
first and foremost as also the Western
set which he mentioned it is the all the
debate and all the our common position
that we finally were quite common quite
similar on the MFF because we have so
many clothes and composition so many
politics but finally when it comes to
the multi-annual financial framework
this is the crucial issue and is not for
is not a mistake that at the moment
nothing has has not been until now
agreed on the next time ffs and the most
of the work is still in the end aidanu
Commission parliament and council to
start now on the base of the proposal of
one year ago and on this the position of
our two committee were on key topics
very very close and the first was we
both from our perspective stressed that
we can not sacrifi
the old successful priority for the new
needed priority it means that the CIP
and cohesion cannot be sacrified when
they succeed for the new ones but the
second means that we have to be strong
Alice for an increase you but we had to
be serious you cannot increase the 40%
of priority and the need with lowering
the budget and the third has been that
we have finally to become serious after
more than 10 years of useless debate
about the own resources on this we took
very strong common position we even take
some coordinated work and so that's also
way that we have had a reciprocal
influence the second one has been the
the world done by this committee it has
been perhaps a new way starting from the
five scenarios
the debate in the future over because
it's good today we are starting our
discussion on the conference of the
future Europe but it was just two years
ago the president young has set up a
document on phy scenario launching the
proposal of a large debate the
Commission has done 700 of dialogue the
comedy written has Lance for the first
time a large debate in the community
that has been concluded in a big event
in book in in Bucharest it was for
delivering your contribution the
contribution of the city of the regional
local authority toward the CBO summit
and for the first time we did also that
the similar a similar process in another
way and we are both to push on this but
unfortunately we have not invited even
for two minutes in the summit of CBO to
present the contribution of the coming
the regional so I would say this to
example just arrived and this work this
joint work on this debate on the yunkai
plan for the future of Europe has been
the inspiration for us both to ride an
on paper because we took stock that
there was a need to make a structure and
tomatoes a necessity not only to solicit
eight people to participate but also to
commit to people to say what has been
the conclusion what has been taken on
board of what we had you have suggested
so these are two example for which I
very very grateful we take a lesson from
your worker for your good result Thank
You presidential yes so clearly the good
cooperation continues mrs. wolf Mighty's
what is your experience when did you
feel the influence of the Committee of
regions well I think that primarily it
has been important to see that the
regional and the city representatives
really were those who helped to show
that Europe is near to the people and I
think what's most important is that
people really feel that it's not people
far away
but it's people who everyday work
together with them who know their
problems are those who shape European
policies and of course my first and most
important interests were in cohesion
policy on dengue dust Aquarians politic
in F a gang height there a photostat sue
baguette Hagen had our an arson and a
driftin fauna lady on on our pho onion
sofa Hindon when divert shaft lesion
alfoil processor
Todd set leash a Hitler Ferengi bottom -
August Aladdin's the site a finance
cruiser on first act which defines the
global easy honk on digital easy wrong
via and it's who name despite rocked a
gazelle shaft 11 and the feeder fur
grows and is fulfill its mission start
on land fakie on dizzy up ganked fern
went vac sander and solid are is Iran
stand ensign Dido achieved our Congress
extrema on Frampton find leha
anti-democratic
Patent Office Afghan when this tank is
worth an evasion pleasure of Kaaba faded
Zukunft sign after the steeples yawns
politic niched and inland they are Mugen
ant madam Tim great London tasse de
gankelaar Gaddafi is dusty burgesses in
oil opa alcohol-fueled want a see ela
problema on - gentlemen of the fogger
happy albeit punished for art minor
problem illusion the sphere da by blind
man tostada area vitae Hin and Vista
college field thank you thank you very
much so we have already talked about the
past and we've already had a few
glimpses that the future in several of
the opinions that we have heard now's
the time to really look ahead and to do
that I would like to turn to another
former president
the committee of regions mr. Luke Vanden
bond mr. hundin bond if you were
president now in the current political
context which are the priorities that
you would want to to give to the
committee of regions where would you
like the committee of regions to to go
[Music]
else villain are the two comes to
community rec overmedicated terrific
blicket anything yet mr. Birmingham
second that is that over they are hain
at committee inverse tech rep OCC 15
Ramadan in begin my removal boost a
valid said that belong Greek is that
word visa Haven that is the institution
error of draft my dang that rogue notes
across Aminata initiative at the name on
the visibility at cannot commit a
well-crafted market and that is the red
bar over the Earlham the column the
entrepreneurial region of the year and
Villandry
initiative over the era hain have a
Canova proceeds of the visibility at
birthmark vomit rhetoric elevated that
black reaches that also add visa hell
vac need further harm than the inner
circle from the insulin and the road
mullah catus who maki the brief not a
european
almost a platter on the hill energy my
raft what sudden double angry kappa
design for the two coasts na z k3 and it
is the east that were many card Sega's
ocicat mean that committee would add
some comfort zone Coleman and neat
louder business as usual development of
event in here do not renew the dam
anything this makan discussion over at
format and over the reservoir up married
in DeLand a normal bed resulted Totoro
PES anserine world European most evil
very click coupled and the rats Anita at
Parliament and Senate Andre Hughes and
Danita lain in the really his lot even
faster Marty Oliver breaking deals at
mark from the whithaven the fast were
the impacts are the heavy and deals and
from the platform he manova Travis is
that an update Vinod food reform a
street and remove this hood on the rogue
anemic wait at Sony or elope applause on
tout or the my as without needin very
scary verdict new in the comfort zone at
the Blair it isn't we depend this a
terrible aggregate committee hood
function eight crafted Dorset machinable
Agni is that owns normal on twinklet our
center of excellence center of
excellence
um anglich the scrutiny to dune run the
administrative fiscal and political a
centralized I see does essential where
the two comes barbarous anglich in
diverse cylinder star Tatiana entered
slaughter enlarge the print were
Stanford an blank moment an average the
conference over the to concern a rope ax
at committee would involve class Delhi
that would form ill-lit
world from the conference II for the two
curves on Europa on the table Dima near
Oakland and Jeff that when are the
outreach nor the main server overshot
that when an essence a little were
villain the neural rats visual needs la
you know Zobrist whenever in start same
um dimension central Stella Rehan refer
Khalifa net on the in it is in else and
combina Sivan member states than started
the units of the East Platts restraint
of the citizens of the mention and as
the reader on that refer in human
centric approach with an equal at words
from Johannes Paris the trade
engineering brain not slot the is a
state and inhale buying Recaro you spell
theft in the decennial
Oxford Committee want DARS under in the
mood of an an anthelmintic
third committee know how Ted beeper
accent
and at elite status door spring click
was an expiry cut that live over the
mid-river inning than the European
double over the earth breading van
Europa and what they say is drinking
from belong for the two cups same print
was this neat bang anything that were
taken and the two curves that we need
bang magazine um the spray can for
Europa on the handle for Europa that we
need bang magazine on the Mensa Central
Marcia need bang magazine amaura Pelton
margin nearly NAR the in-stream are
eating to that Stadium and Ray Hughes an
essence a Laplace he named in the blood
forming this in the democracy for Europa
thank you thank you mr. Van Daan bond
Miss Cochran Miss Ann Sophie Buccaneer
the president of the association of
border regions and God knows we do have
a lot of those in Europe in fact Europe
is the continent in the world with the
highest border concentration so what do
you think the committee of regions can
do to eliminate these borders which
remain obstacles and barriers for our
citizens thank you ladies and gentlemen
I think although we have a quite
comfortable juror we also have a new
generation of effect of cross border of
obstacles to overcome so we are but it's
coming more obstacles and even in in
Hamas a serviced sophisticated crossbody
areas they will also get new ones and
see although this board rate has have a
long history of making and over to
overcome these obstacles we still need
new instruments for for using using and
helping these border regions for example
there are new needs
such as provision of cross-border public
service that new upcoming obstacles
other regions are still in need of
stronger incentives of more cohesion our
commitment within the cohesion Alliance
is to keep or even increase funding for
cohesion in particular territory
cohesion the external borders and our
neighbors beyond are facing many
obstacles due to geopolitics and other
factors such as migration phenomena
however all of us have to be concerned
by a common challenge unite forces to
adapt to climate change and take very
seriously the sustainable development
goals so to concrete we have new border
obstacles when we have overcome some but
we also have many borders that still
need much more funding for overcoming
these obstacles and never forget the
climate change thank you thank you very
much miss Perriman and thank you very
much for being a short and concise I
would like to continue our tour of
guests here on the on the floor of the
hemicycle and I'd like to turn to mr.
Valmont had a mayor who's also former
president of the Committee of regions a
couple of weeks ago mr. DeMaio the
committee of regions held a conference
in in Rome on subsidiarity back in 1998
where subsidiarity was already talked
about you said and I quote subsidiarity
should not be wishful thinking but it
should be one of the preconditions to
set up a new Europe now do you think
would you say that the committee is on
the right track now
field Lankford is a frog subsea levitate
- and fog an eye on aesthetics big
loafer with him they all show steady on
sir about nuttin when they all show star
Yan is one entry field and Suzanne the
field as a decent beginner if he isn't
conceived in a whopper get on first off
Todd it's for the maastricht Fatah he
Direction lender from the Bundesliga on
Fallon does a sign also Sturridge own
games altered had bundeskanzler Elmwood
Cole guns lugar game even in deutschland
on the stoic assist gained in villain
the mice under an older patient Landis
video on getting the invading the
underbelly given they are also stellar
Yan is become French done when they are
also stellar Yan is for fleshed it does
for Suzette's subsidary ta Tata by a
mine of Allagash Peru necklace we feel
like the system Suzette's and he have a
decent hour shows in convent for
threatened orphan and us via da is doing
he said Stubb 34 face on the subsidiary
tell an estate and and Principia n--
allah corporation Institute's earnest
vac eine kleine it kite on beam emerging
leader stand on the central Canada mine
on cam does as business as usual
dusters Alice Logan's alphabet again
water via mission owns the home come on
dusters white agate it been Xia they
also stay on the darf which was fastened
our competency as actually established
aluminum object Minoan all sod and
demands Halton can order of Nick Luke
fandom and Atif ensemble for a global as
a switch the hist theta off for
supervisor does as Denise Merkley arises
over Russian Vida and convent game can
understand and are overridden was we
know a whopper the master fire miss
Australia transmission Institute zone
on each muffler they can earn hanger so
over there a yawn bin
if lifted us they are also still a
yonder by starkwood here lever as
Mercedes Brazil glad to for built leash
and as I didn't see a TV immoral person
parliamentary fog not when he's wearing
avulsion the South they're also stereo
nzy of Anna's or his it was shown for a
belated undone that Susan when the
expression for wrong translation it's a
upstream of steel that's who get as
mission or Darwin evicting in Principia
n-- beginning that if the doors arms and
VD effect on Anna finale on which the
incursions political foreign so tribe
son as well Alderaan gain and Ponder's
of ensue muffin
when geeing verdict more patient
Parliament in their commercial integrity
like a master of a great advert there's
a starting game hunter Dean demon behalf
muster des I advise your patience wished
for all over persevered and it often on
the Stafford original fur on the Kurds
burns altar is trucked or phones than
Muslims then also they're a young of
Wotan
as Fantine and shyrone game but in
Azeroth Zetas and not see another
youngest referred West returns all on
this is Rafa all these like ancillary on
first
there are McMahon's Ian thus they are
also stereo no physician does the
reunion your exam fight after safely
mere competency mashed inflows of our
page in our Muslim and as a sneak no and
no providers discussion steamer analysis
Ines the saunière demands a meat-eater
he Noah Gifford version was well of God
and the fields hunter Sheila Harrison
said he reverted from offshore survey on
fairness informants 1cr there's a decent
of God hoped when he reverted as a
diesel come a felon come in them
thoroughly and brightest bluntness so
far in dongjun
attention of over PA mm shotgun thank
you very much mr. de mayor for a very
clear goal for the coming 25 years let
me ask you mr. Anderson Appa mr.
Schnapper you're the executive president
of the Council of European
municipalities and region DC's CEM are
and indeed your organization has played
a key role in the inception of this
institution but you're also the
president of the congress of local and
regional authorities of the Council of
Europe so another dimension and in your
view how could the committee of regions
principle of self-governance for region
and local authorities apply to the
future what what angle would you take
thank you so much for giving me the
opportunity to speak on behalf of CMR
and on the Congress in in Strasbourg and
I fully agree with a lot of things that
has been said here before but I wanted
to have as a message for for for this
celebration here is that you can hear in
the debate in many member countries in
the political debate that the problem in
Europe is the European Union the evil in
Europe is the European Union the
European Union created all the problems
but if you look at it a little bit
closer today the same politicians are
talking about the importance of the
local and regional authorities and the
importance of local and regional
politicians and the clew to be close to
the citizens the big problem is today is
not the European Union the big problem
today from my point of view is the
national governments the national
governments who take away powers instead
of giving powers to local and regional
authorities taking away resources from
local and regional authorities instead
of giving them resources creating an
atmosphere there that all the cleverness
or the Adrienne's in way is in
national level and we are some sort of
deliver on what they are deciding I
think this is one of the big issues we
have to discuss between Zuma between the
Congress between the Committee of the
regions in the future who we can give
local and regional politicians and
citizens really say in what's happening
in the member countries the European
Union is not the problem the problem is
the situation we have at home and we
have to be united and we have to work
together to solve that
I hope this conference also can be
possible the conference that the
Commission is setting up also to debate
the importance not only of dinner
speeches saying that we are important
also to deliver the tools that we can
deliver to the citizens thank you thank
you very much another clear goal for
this conference on the future of Europe
and now talking more about the future of
the committee I would like to turn to
three of our members starting if you
allow me with miss Doran Hobart miss ha
dirt is a representative of Renu europe
and she's a councillor in Newcastle City
Council miss Hubbard - madam Ransome I'd
like to start again by apologizing to
everyone for the damage that brexit has
and will cause you all it was not the
choice of my party or myself and
whatever happens with the UK elections I
expect that this will be my last plenary
so I'd like to take the opportunity to
recall how committee of regions has had
active contributions from UK members
who've shown real commitment to the aims
of the organisation and the development
of local and regional government if I
can name some why probably start with
graham talk Lord top a founding member
first leader of the liberal group and
chair of the old const commission also
flock Lucas
houki who became president of the Auld a
group chaired the ad hoc commission on
the EU budget and is now a member of
congress in her retirement not
forgetting people like Paula Baker Doris
I'm sorry
Graham Garvey Ruth Coleman and Jill
Shortland from all sides of the the UK
and they were all active participants so
whatever happens after brexit the work
of the cor must continue your work adds
value and contributes to the democratic
process for the citizens you represent
and finally I'd like to pay tribute to
the excellent staff and Secretariat of
the Brussels office and the Secretariat
here for their country continued hard
work their support and their well
informed advice we will miss you and I
am very pleased to hear that a joint cor
UK contract group will be established so
that we can continue to exchange
dialogue and ideas in the future I wish
you all good luck I hope that you will
treasure the CEO and I would like to say
au revoir mezzo me thank you very much
thank you for this great kind tributes
I'd like to turn to mr. Eldredge Plaza
mr. Vlasak you're the vice president of
the ECR group here in the committee of
regions and how do you see the evolution
of the committee dear president dear
honorable guests one of the former
British Prime Minister's used to say one
week is a long time in politics the
European Committee of the region has
been on the institutional map of
Brussels for 25 years we are a page in
history we are mentioned in every book
in every university seminar dedicated to
your
in integration we are fighting hard to
have our voice heard in Brussels on some
occasions we succeeded on others the
fact that the committee of the region's
is the conservative consultative body
prevents us from having a lasting impact
but one thing is certain we have always
done our best to represent the voice of
our local communities I started my
political career at EU level in
committee of the regions then I was
elected to European Parliament and the
last two years I served as a vice
president responsible for lations with
Committee of the regions at that time we
signed agreement between committee of
the regions and Parliament and then
since that the meetings between Reggie
and coder started these meetings are an
example to be followed in terms of good
Intel institutional cooperation they are
still ongoing the last one took place in
October this year I'm happy that some
progress was made in the cooperation but
I also know this that the progress in
deepening our relations with other
institutions is too slow that's why I
hope that the 25th anniversary of the
creation of the committee of the regions
will serve as a platform to not only
celebrate our anniversary but also to
reflect upon our future thank you for
attention
thank you mr. black and I'd like now to
turn to mr. sean own Acton who is the
former president of the ei group in the
committee of regions Thank You guru
market volume lower T Mahan go woohoo
Chevelle get a guitar no sir dementia he
he could blend of imaging shows genre
more Shahana Norah Duskull question
Dragoon and road to lesson dog thinking
it again
Edgar Garcia Agatha Norbert identical
gallery August 2nd may on to learn more
of Aurora Gunawan Cora Greece ignore in
sagasta Shah Mohammad latina hog much
institute new reward AG establish a
modest politician august how much egg
toward tuckered bernardino a how much
ignore homer go parliament ahora pom
arrested in the Asian jibe remedy as
lava healer
Tasha naka Levine surveil guy Darren
Neely article Aquila Tommy the Waukesha
ago borislav Aquila no ago Burress
Agumon feign action in chapter of behold
a [ __ ] Tawana agus can follow us our
gold star serving on rat Amon Carter
Harlem noggin to follow boss tagging on
Greg knew after stock oxen-free or pujas
near fatal Linea marina at all are sung
partner of the Sherpa ligand ocean
tarlowe Shechem who will towel ordered
an argon washed ashore August here the
Goblin of the Polamalu jana gana eyebrow
crushed in Rangoon collages latina there
we farm and Europa
listen officially or post ring
initiation Marissa honey met Chang while
ago Mila cashed in the Reagan obviously
bond touch two more as shame nor the hog
modes and chapter of Tawana guru Mila
Maggie August rasoolum camara agus chain
or a so who'd blame defeated at Hamas
ruin her mother
Thank You mr. igniting um miss wolf
Matias I'm a little the translation
finish yes it's always a little bit
longer in German I'll turn to you again
you were a haunt my as we say in French
so a very privileged
witness of the beginnings of this of
this committee since you were at the
time European Commissioner in charge of
regional policy and and cohesion so what
would your wish list be I mean it's
almost Christmas so now's the time what
what would your wish list be for this
committee in the coming years yeah if
denker digit Watson had seafarin that
Onvia elevation dusty cousin kablammo
anthracite nish solutions and owner
initial conk tell regional institution
dimension when toss toss in infer
gangnam yarn or CF Avista gaze climb
Evangeline unveiled shots Bauman Moscow
Schneider regionalism nice newer foodie
Cola Reagan son an ecologist at and fake
long narcotic is found on red font Lea
fakirs concept simplistic about China
Korea why young ones like a matte sealer
when Tosca managed Van Orden Fartman son
and Aziz was vastly Gans concrete in in
statement command on in the region up
speared our Heine over PA McCarthy owns
politic
calmed own ad understood song from
statement combine in game the integrity
on fun fleshling Gillibrand Masonic Taos
want women innovation strategy gnomes
Edison will then Bachman and Suzanne
veal from virtue after avakov fir Benton
Hawkes Xuan on definitely have a Vuitton
Prada of La Jolla Andre canalla
Abner Ventus killings all on the tanker
does of I'll decent felon the Albert de
Sade L met Simon idiot even went Nets
racoon fish decomposes its most as heist
adventure Mia das via grader as an
Starcraft Act Eve sinned
oome sociology I drunk so far mine
vos profession is yeah off dust arduous
mission wah mention Lydon son and a
softy integral internets and Olivet
perhaps fish guide to our Pearson on yon
but i'm tresh destroyed on decide plow
missus vista da da da da vitamark voix
onf a gang had aborted namely mere
invested see own inner friendly she
designs for saga in buildings iron rich
tongue in fakirs vega in the digital
infrastructure sue father an anti
politic this virtually non sati on and
off territory on saddam heights by emma
and a vista Gazzola their operation
integrity on then read proverbs to a
kite when solidarity occurrences am on
des abbesses mere bizarreness wished a
decent pumped mi vida to return even
shamea - taotie austerity on Xena
function as an vitae stator and rake
Yohn untied speaker threshing burger
Vandenberg on until our operation
Institute shown in didi butter indeed su
comforter hope as I'm blinged consummate
closer and she denied
asking about annoying Committee on want
him knowing our patient Parliament fat
which then he device as good when Allah
here quietly on revista area is about
skipped speed are done of concrete a
problem when they say basis we steal our
dusty MIT leader this RAL here here
opposites you on Busan - stark Martin
once is Alton and let's just see certain
also house a tight leash man does
regionally interesting
dunk terabyte is out shows aesthetic Yan
in Brasilia will be after dwellin then D
critique and then under our patient on
you Anisha and Gabe Lima yo undemocratic
stroke to her until a burger found Abbas
e-reading for admitting Bergen went
Mia does he discussed after Eva Albert
went to hear political cycnus for arts
or advising davia honey in neuro feel
afford version Afton Easton Furman
Swansea Yahoo when he finished as he
inclined by Trotter to lies in content
Thank You mrs. Wilfer wolf Matthias
could I invite president Lambert's to
join me down here
the floor is now yours
Maxie bakui the cocoons of all to really
that psycho does in patita set extra
ordinary to Conservancy to Brasilia Fox
kill for poor country but on events I
can a portion much I'm another grant on
early you see companies here the metal
owner knows or is it all in wouldn't
above a preferred YC Jacque blonde drag
I Taylor from here presi-donut the
committee is a people knew CIA was a
real emotional particle then is known
Connor Lucas negotiation is vital year
done Davi hits Manfred Amaya
Soumya beating
finding us CRT Inglot Commons in
Midlands - Zaman visa for infants fancy
jihad soufiane what I see but it's to
come - Susanna and the family yes good
[Music]
and now I like to talk to turn to see
audible the Arbor I think we have been
saying our goodbyes for about three
years now
no one can predict the future but I
knows it's a relationship with our
English colleagues will continue no
matter what I would like to send my
greetings to all of them through you and
thank you very much for your work here a
[Applause]
news on equipment and ranch wagon now
here's the Komen Zalman Mitch volleyed
and just
Chabert Michele Dubois and itself
couldn't buy second but the belly sharee
goes he'll hoot for take involved if you
are on a top funded committee von
Drago's Maui Hilton based on the Baraka
hidden human dilemma tight inhale
concrete and on cajeta money davao great
Arctic bedankt andrew crow is the last
ceci and acquainted best for the two
constant
[Applause]
Minho's review today appellee open mommy
Exodus
that's it espresso a companion come on
party the more popular Baku SEO
community really should be a tutorial
six a day
Natasha's copolymer level failure
Mercedes at Allah premiered a juice
capris on heelas unique family Teton
atrocity Co a for the deal to determine
or prefer me miss approved shell method
s maxi pituitary tumors are popped AOC
Panola County Parliament pass conse
conse comment Matt Nam you to excel vba
cotton our Parliament eval pea Kiev Remo
and also president the committee and
finally I am specially glad to call to
call makuu macula to the stage my dear
colleague insist mandate we sue my work
in tandem for five years
makuu I would like to thank you very
much for your good cooperation and we
will continue to see us together here in
the next Monday but not as standing on
the top what is ordinary members of sis
committee thank you very much
[Applause]
of Apple Mighty Mouse ear over
matsyasana president you know popular
via new table just jean bethke the DCD
sweetly motion eagle no Monsieur
maja girl help the Labov of Val Cassell
a mission lebra you notice country
Donnie design pills you are not the
committee for the return his own
president if you will do that you see a
room at seat to remove to committee he
afforded Tsavo extraordinaire kazaaam
bukit ohnkoji he don't certain party on
vehicles Audrey OSI layer down yet CC on
the premier Appling Jeff you see abou
cell Maxie buku had to serve to settle a
despair to continue our very contact
yeah who below Li di t loss Adrian you
know McHale days are see any results
here do committee or PR agency potato in
treble needy available como él paga at
really easy
merci beaucoup in continue or not were
activity Matt no Lord Allah reception
elusive on our LoCascio
to the vanilla cava people particularly
our mantra by the not personally the
zhurqis delish Mexico ku-ku-ku-ku
sandstone divert attention Walker Pascal
who's ever covering Daphnia petite
family a young Korean fitted for Mary
Taylor salteena Paris she lost venial
cetera a donkey and thank no sir man
tanker LCM president unique resident
immersive as create a moment most of the
group I can consider president firma de
Toledo name one or no the to Lizotte
refreshingness
you know natural Monday to remember the
committee
[Applause]
can I now invite all speakers off
tonight to come for a group photograph
but on this side with the hemicycle
behind them on that side
[Applause]
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
we are now inviting you to join us for
the reception at the committee of
Regions Building have a very nice
evening